[Music]
kids love dressing up for halloween
that's the you know you see some adults
dressing up here and there yeah i see
out there but it's really about kids you
know and we wanted to do something for
kids out there so if you're a kid and
you waited until the last second to come
up with a costume
don't you worry our very own costume
designer scott cronic is going to show
you how to make a really quick and easy
halloween costume scott
hey kids don't worry if you don't have a
costume yet for halloween i'm going to
show you how to make a great ghost
costume in just four easy steps hey kids
let's make a ghost costume
all right step one gather your costume
staff and start delegating tasks based
on your preliminary sketches
so first we're gonna need to build the
harness susan i'm gonna have you start
working on cutting the pipes assembling
the medical plastic linda i'm gonna have
you start on the outer shell we're using
this sparkle spandex here all right
let's get started okay kids now that
your team is hard at work making the
basic foundation of the costume it's
time for step two
consulting your show's special effects
expert
here at conan kids i work with a great
guy named eric allard hopefully your
show's special effects guy is as
talented as eric so i'm showing the kids
at home how to make a simple ghost
costume obviously their special effects
needs take the time to thoroughly go
over how your show special effects
expert plans on executing each effect
okay
you've delegated to your costume game
and your special effects guy is busy at
work now this could take a while so it's
time for step three
taking a minute to relax and reflect
[Music]
thank you
you know sometimes amidst all the chaos
it's very important to take some me time
to really reflect on all the hard work
and sacrifice that got you here as a
successful costume designer
here's to me
step four supervising the final assembly
of your costume and fitting it on your
stump man i'll see you on tv
it's easy kids let's take a look at the
finished costume bring it out scott
[Applause]
yes thank you thank you for showing the
kids at home how to make this simple
costume
anything for the kids conan all right
we'll take a break